der politische mega Aufreger während
Millionen Deutsche Existenzängste haben
will Olaf Scholz fast eine Milliarde
Euro für den Umbau des Kanzleramts
verschleudern hier regiert der Kanzler
auf über 25.000 Quadratmetern doch die
die sind ihm offenbar nicht genug ja das
Kanzleramt das ist einfach zu klein und
soll deshalb für
777 Millionen Euro umgebaut werden
777 Millionen Euro ja eine Zahl kaum
fassbar und das während die Deutschen in
der Krise stecken
darf ein bisschen mehr sein wie wäre es
mit einem Hubschrauber Landeplatz auf
Stelzen einer Kita und rund 4009 Büros
diese und viele weitere Extras soll die
geplante Erweiterung des Kanzleramts
haben es ist ein gigantisches Bauprojekt
inklusive gigantischer Kosten für
777 Millionen Euro soll die bisherige
Bürofläche von 25.000 Quadratmeter auf
50.000 Quadratmeter vergrößert werden
davon allein 2,8 Millionen Euro für die
Kita mit gerade einmal 15 Plätzen und 10
Millionen Euro für den Hedi Landeplatz
auf 23 Meter hohen Stelzen außerdem
geplant eine zweite kanzler-wohnung von
250 Quadratmetern Fertigstellung 2028
wow aber Moment mal damit wäre das
Kanzleramt größer als das Weiße Haus die
Downing Street number ten in London und
der elise-palast in Paris brauchen Olaf
Scholz und Co wirklich so viel Platz und
Politik zu machen offenbar schon Kritik
vom Bundesrechnungshof aus dem Herbst
2020 Abenteuer Bau verhalte ungehört
jetzt soll mitten in der schwersten
Krise der Bundesrepublik mit dem Bau
begonnen werden das Projekt ist völlig
überdimensioniert es passt nicht in die
Zeit und es haben ja schon einige davor
gewarnt unter anderem auch der
Bundesrechnungshof dass die
veranschlagten Kosten so nicht haltbar
sind wir kommen von 475 Millionen Euro
sind jetzt schon bei über 650 Millionen
Euro und ich gehe davon aus dass dieser
Bau nicht unter einer Milliarde Euro
mindestens zu haben wird wenn das
überhaupt eine Benchmark ist die
erreicht werden kann steigende Preise
wohin man nur schaut Corona pleitewellen
und ein drohender Blackout im Winter wie
passt da dieser protzbau ins Programm
tatsächlich stammt die ursprüngliche
Idee noch aus den Zeiten von
ex-kanzlerin Merkel damals ging es
Deutschland allerdings noch extrem gut
jetzt sieht das ganz anders aus doch
könnte man den Umbau noch stoppen würden
dafür Kosten anfallen eine bildanfrage
dazu liest das Kanzleramt unbeantwortet
aus meiner Sicht brauchen wir zurzeit
überhaupt keinen Neubau weil zu es geht
ja alle Mitarbeiter sind ausgelagert wir
haben Büroplätze in anderen Ministerien
die frei sind darüber hinaus haben wir
gelernt dass auch vieles von zu Hause
ausgeht Stichwort Homeoffice trotz
Krisenzeit soll der Bau durchgezogen
werden und dafür müssten laut the
pioneer 180 Bäume die bis zu 60 Jahre
alt sind gefällt und 40 weitere
umgesetzt werden 200 Bäume sollen dann
als Ausgleich im späteren kanzlergarten
gepflanzt werden
ja sprechen wir weiter über diesen trotz
Bau bei uns im Studio Bild
tv-chefredakteur Klaus Strunz Klaus
jeder Deutsche dreht gerade jeden Tag
jeden Cent um wie Pasta dieser portsbau
für 777 Millionen Euro rein die Zahl
muss man einfach noch mal nennen naja
das ist eine absolute Unverschämtheit
und man man muss Olaf Scholz zurufen
Herr Bundeskanzler treten Sie jetzt auf
die Notbremse ziehen Sie die Notbremse
bei diesem Protz klotz-bau der passt
nicht in die Zeit er ist eine
unglaubliche Frechheit und es ist eine
absolute Unverschämtheit von Olaf Scholz
und seinen in umgebenden Mitarbeitern
wenn sie auf Fragen antworten wir bauen
ja für die Ewigkeit also was da für eine
Geisteshaltung dahinter steht da fehlt
ja der zweite Satz die wir so wir bauen
für die Ewigkeit und nehmen euer Geld
ihr Lieben bürgerlein dafür und wenn ihr
dann zu Hause friert oder wenn ihr euch
eure Supermarkt Rechnung nicht mehr
leisten könnt macht nichts ihr baut ja
mit an der Ewigkeit eine solche
Unverschämtheit in einer wie dieser ist
unglaublich und dieser Bau ist noch
bevorer begonnen hat bereits das Symbol
für die Verabschiedung von Politikern
von der Wirklichkeit und vom Leben der
Leute Olaf Scholz der immer so tut als
sei er sozusagen so nah an den Menschen
der sich als Sozialdemokrat den
sogenannten kleinen Leuten verbunden
fühlt baut sich ein 777 Millionen eures
teures Kanzleramt und wischt jede Kritik
daran vom Tisch der sagt noch nicht mal
erklärt's noch nicht mal wenn er sich
hinstellt und sagt ja liebe Bürger das
kommt Ihnen und Euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich komisch vor aber das muss
sein aus diesem Grund aus diesem Grund
aus diesem Grund aus diesem Grund okay
dann ziehe ich noch mein Hut dann hat
der Mann wie Oliver Kahn sagen wird Eier
aber erwischt es weg mit wer sich
darüber aufregt ist ein kleines
bürgerlein das um sein Geld wir haben
ihr Denken in großen Dimensionen die
einzig große Dimension der ich im Moment
denke ist das totale Versagen dieser
Regierung der Grund dafür ist warum man
sich beant das wahrscheinlich gibt's gar
keinen Grund das sagt ja auch der Bund
der Steuerzahler wir brauchen eigentlich
keinen riesen neuen protzbau weil alle
Mitarbeiter eigentlich versorgt sind und
es ist eigentlich alles in Ordnung und
wir müssen uns ja auch noch einmal
vorstellen Olaf Scholz ist in im
Wahlkampf angetreten mit ja nur ein oder
zwei wirklichen versprechen ein
Versprechen war wir bauen Wohnungen wir
brauchen ganz viele Wohnungen für
Menschen die sich Wohnungen ich man kann
jetzt sozusagen ironisch zugespitzt sein
dieses Wahlversprechen löste ein für
sich selbst er baut sich eine 250
Quadratmeter Wohnung obwohl er im
jetzigen Kanzleramt schon eine hat die
übrigens da war ich mal ganz schön
hübsch ist 99% der deutschen wohnen
nicht so schön wie der Kanzler jetzt
schon im Kanzleramt aber nein er baut
sich eine größere das ist so ich also
man spürt es ja vielleicht in einer Zeit
wo wir jeden Tag schreiben senden lesen
wo die Menschen zu Hause nicht mehr
wissen was sie mit ihrer wohin mit ihrer
Abschlagszahlung wo
sozusagen Existenzen auf dem Spiel
stehen wo Wirtschaftsunternehmen darum
vergangen bei der Arbeitsplätze zur
Verfügung stellen zu können wo dieses
Land sozusagen in einer noch nie da
gewesenen Krise ist baut dieser Mann
sich ein ein neues Gebäude für am Ende
wird es eine Milliarde sein denn das
kennen wir ja vom ber dem legendären
Flughafen und Scholz selber kennt es
auch von der Elbphilharmonie in Hamburg
die auch mit wenig relativ wenig Budgets
begonnen hat und dann nach oben durch
die Decke teuer war so wird es da aus
sein und jetzt kommt der Punkt sozusagen
jetzt kommt der Punkt den man obwohl es
Gas einmal deutlich sagen muss es ist ja
nicht Olaf Scholz Geld es ist unser Geld
es sind 777 Millionen Euro Steuergelder
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin
eigentlich ein Freund vom Steuern zahlen
weil es natürlich eine richtige Idee ist
dass jeder sich beteiligt an
modernisierungsprojekten an der
Infrastruktur daran das Straßen
ausgebessert werden daran dass wir bei
5g kleiner Schatz das war bei der
Digitalisierung Weiterkommen das
schlucke ich alles gern aber wenn ich
mir vorstelle dass auch nur ein Euro von
meinem Geld in diesem trotz Bau in
dieser Krise geht dann verstehe ich die
Welt nicht mehr und ich kann dann
wirklich langsam verstehen dass ich die
allgemeine Meinung dahin gehend oder
immer mehr Anhänger findet dass die
Repräsentanten unserer Demokratie nur
eins richtig gut können ihre Bürger
abzuzocken ja und ihn dann auch noch
schöne Tipps zu geben waschlappendips
und Durchfall und ähnliches dazu
Kretschmann der Verursacher dieses
Waschlappen äh Vergleichs zum Abendessen
zur Olaf Scholz fährt in die 250
Quadratmeter Wohnung unsere klügeln dass
die Leute doch lieber ein Waschlappen
nehmen sollen als warm zu duschen so das
wird nicht passieren denn 2028 soll der
Unsinn ja erst fertig sein der ist stolz
auch schon nicht mehr Kanzler insofern
baut er für sein Nachfolger danke Olaf
ja und dann werden Berlin sind baute
wahrscheinlich für den nach Nachfolger
und Klaus es kommt ja noch ein zweites
Problem dazu es gibt auch noch um die
Bäume und wir wissen ja wir haben eine
ampelregierung da sind auch grüne drin
Viktor Wachs ist für uns am
Bundeskanzleramt also Viktor dutzende
Bäume sollen für diesen trotzbau einfach
weg und die Grünen in der Ampel stürzt
null
die Grünen in der Ampel scheint
überhaupt nicht zu stören wie Klaus
strunzer gerade schon gesagt hat
Kretschmann wird bei Scholz zu Gast sein
in der 250 Quadratmeter Wohnung die
kommt genau hierhin wo ich jetzt stehe
Feli wenn ihr mal mitkommen wollte dass
es hier ein wirkliches Biotop mitten in
Berlin die Grünen sagen immer so etwas
soll gerettet werden wenn ihr mir mal
folgen wollt hier sind alle möglichen
Arten von Bäumen es ist wirklich ein
kleines Naturparadies hier sind Akazien
hier sind Lianen und vor allem sind hier
auch Eichen die wie wir vorhin in den
Beitrag gesehen haben abgeholzt werden
sollen und was ist Deutscher als eine
deutsche Eiche die kommt jetzt hier weg
alles verschwindet nur wegen der
Gigantomanie von Olaf Scholz also auch
da sehen wir ein eine wirklich schöne
Natur und die Grünen die scheint nicht
zu interessieren auch da wieder ein
Signal wo man sich so denkt da greift
man sich doch an den Kopf gibt es nicht
so ein Wirtschafts-
jeden Tag irgendwo rumrennt und sich
weigert AKWs abzuschalten
und den Schiffen also die kommen sollen
und als Dreckschleudern sozusagen
rum produzieren sollen vor unseren
Küsten also der Mann ist ja da und gibt
sich auch eine Außenministerin lass mich
kurz nachdenken eine grüne Frau die
Waffen liefert und alles mögliche also
die ohnehin schon mehrere wichtige
Säulen ihre eigenen politischen
Biografie und das Überzeugungen für
diese stand und derartigen sie gewählt
worden ist geschreddert hat gibt es die
nicht und müssten die nicht zur Olaf
Scholz gehen und sagen also
Bundeskanzler
wir machen jetzt diesen Bau auf keinen
Fall mit sondern unser Rad ist stoppen
Sie diesen Bau sonst machen wir das
nämlich öffentlich dann haben wir ein
richtig schönes Thema in der Koalition
und wir können doch einfach wenn die
Krise vorbei ist dann legen ihre Beamten
das ganze noch mal auf Wiedervorlage das
können die sowieso super ja alles auf
Wiedervorlage kennen wir aus dem
Finanzamt aus Wiedervorlage aus dem
Bürgeramt Wiedervorlage wieder von die
Wiedervorlage Spezialisten rund um Olaf
Scholz könnten doch einfach dieses
Projekt jetzt auf Eis legen und wir
sprechen 2025 noch mal darüber dann aber
vielleicht schon gar nicht mit ihm der
Vorschlag von Klaus Strunz danke schön
[Musik]